Hi, I’m Evan Carmichael.
Welcome to another edition of Ask Evan.
In today’s episode I’m going to answer a question
from one of my forum readers Don
who wrote in asking about success and he said
“As an entrepreneur what has been
your biggest success online?”
So thanks for the question Don.
For me, my biggest success I think
is the launch of evancarmichael.com
and turning that into a business.
So when I sold my first software company
and hooked up with a venture capital company
I was being asked to do a lot of speaking
as a young entrepreneur
kind of success story,
so I used my website evancarmichael.com
basically just to say where I was speaking
and what I was talking about as well
as share some of the famous entrepreneur profiles
that I had found helpful
for me when growing my business.
People who I’ve modeled their success
and was able to build a successful company myself as well.
And that was the launch of the website
and no matter what I was always going to have that website.
I felt it was adding value back to people
who were reading and people would write in
saying that they really love what I wrote
and it was inspiring
and motivated them to keep going with their business
and not give up and you know
that’s awesome stuff, right?
That makes me want to keep going
and doing more and when you get feedback
like that you know you’re doing something right
and you’re on the right track.
It was never intended to be a business at the start.
It was just something that I did
as value add to help people out
and a lot of people helped me
with my business that I started
so I wanted to give back
and it also felt really good
knowing that you’re helping people.
And then when I discovered
‘hey, you know what, we could try some advertising on the website’
and that did well.
That kind of made the click with the website
and that started the process for it to become
my next main business
and so I transitioned out of the venture capital company
and did my evancarmichael.com stuff on the side
while at the VC firm
and when I noticed,
‘hey, this has some serious revenue opportunities as well.
If I could do what I’m really excited about
and make money doing it and help a lot of people
that’s an awesome formula
and I was able to, you know, leave the venture capital company
and pursue evancarmichael.com fulltime
and turned it into a real business.
And that’s what I’m, you know
really proud of, really
probably my biggest success online.
We’ve done a lot of little things to make it better
and better and better on an increasing basis
every day we try to do things to make the company better
but from a big picture point of view
I think being able to launch evancarmichael.com
and get a lot of people coming to it
and be able to turn it into a business
is probably my biggest success online.
So thanks for the question Don.
If you guys liked the video,
please give it a thumbs-up.
It makes me want to do more of these videos for you guys
and if you have a question about success
or another question for your company
feel free to leave it in the comments below.
I always read those and try to respond to as many as I can.
So thank you and I’ll see you on the next episode.